this all started when dua lipa got sued
for posting a photo of herself earlier
this year british singer dua lipa was
sued after allegedly posting a paparazzi
photo of herself on instagram the agency
which owns the picture alleged that the
instagram post violated their copyright
in the image the singer's fans were
understandably confused why couldn't she
post a mundane image of herself standing
in line at an airport well according to
integral images which owns the copyright
lipa's instagram feed acts as a
marketing tool for her music the agency
alleges that the photograph's
intentionally infringed on integral's
copyright and undercut its ability to
profit from the photos after all dualipa
didn't pay to post that photo the
lawsuit seeks the statutory damages for
an intentional copyright violation that
amounts to 150 thousand dollars the
agency is also asking for an order
stopping lipa from further acts of
infringement now duolipo was not the
only famous person sued for posting a
picture of herself splash news sued
jennifer lopez for posting a splash
photo of her holding hands with alex
rodriguez in 2017 a photographer sued
jessica simpson after she posted a photo
of herself leaving the bowery hotel in
new york the photographer said that he
had only licensed the photo for limited
use to the daily mail but simpson and
her social media managers tweeted it out
without licensing it splash news and
picture agencies sued liam hemsworth in
2018 claiming he posted its photos of
him on instagram without the company's
permission paparazzo robert barbera sued
ariana grande after she posted two of
his photos on her instagram in august
2018 and photographer christopher
postieri sued 50 cent after 50 posted
photographs taken by possierie during a
2014 reunion concert with g-unit so do
paparazzi photographers have the right
to stock famous people profit from
selling their images then turn around
and sue the famous person for posting
photographs of themselves
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a copyright lawyer because some of this
is not exactly intuitive now we've
talked about copyright many times on
this channel copyright is a legal device
that gives the creator of a work of art
the right to control how their work is
used when we use the word creator or
author that could mean writers musicians
photographers architects software
developers or even people who design
boats for a living all of them are
considered authors under the american
copyright law and the things that they
produce are works of art the protection
four works of art comes from the
constitution article 1 section 8 clause
8 gives congress the power to quote
promote the progress of science and
useful arts by securing for limited
times to authors and inventors the
exclusive right to their respective
writings and discoveries scientific
pursuits like machines or useful items
are generally given patents but artistic
creations like novels and photographs
are covered by copyright law and because
copyright is provided for in the
constitution it's exclusively bound by
federal law and under 17 usc 106 if you
have a copyright in something you have
the exclusive right to do a number of
things including make copies of that
work of art make adaptations and
derivatives distribute the work publicly
perform a play or perform it in front of
others display at work in public
digitally transmit sound recordings and
in some circumstances the right to
receive attribution and prevent a
destruction of a work and these are the
rights that photographers have when it
comes to their photographs according to
the us copyright office the owner of a
work is generally the person who takes a
photo generally the only time this isn't
the case is when there's a work for hire
contract or you have an employee
employer situation and generally you
don't own the copyright just because you
are the subject of a photo this can even
be the case when a person hires a
photographer to take photos like a
wedding photographer it depends on
what's in the contract but if that
contract is silent then the photographer
owns the copyright to those photos of
the wedding unless the photographer
agreed in writing to transfer or license
the copyrights to that to someone else
presumably the bride and groom and the
damages for a single instance of
infringement can be quite steep under
the copyright act a copyright owner is
entitled to an award of actual damages
and disgorgement of all the infringer's
profits attributable to infringement and
in the alternative the plaintiff can
elect an award of statutory damages for
an amount up to 150 thousand dollars for
each infringement and that takes us to
the paparazzi versus celebrities in the
internet age it's dramatically changed
what's at stake for paparazzi
photographers in the old days they could
take photographs and sell them to the
highest bidder and this was usually a
magazine or a newspaper now with the
internet and social media there's a
whole new market for digital images this
is a blessing and a curse photographers
can get their work seen all over the
world almost instantly but it also
undercuts the market for exclusive
images and made it much easier to
infringe also since everyone has a
camera in their pocket
there's no longer exclusivity when it
comes to photographs of celebrities and
meanwhile celebrities themselves are now
content creators they make a lot of
money by posting images of themselves on
social media accounts and the top
influencer accounts like cristiano
ronaldo can get up to a million dollars
per post and as you can see the rock
ariana grande several sisters kardashian
and several family members jenner are
also believed to earn hundreds of
thousands of dollars per post
photographers and their agencies claim
it isn't fair for celebrities to
distribute images of themselves without
paying for a license for the person who
took that photograph this is the dynamic
that has created the current environment
where celeb photographers are suing the
same people they photograph now there
are lots of these cases but let's talk
about one of the biggest exposure versus
kardashian the uk photo agency licensed
pictures of kardashian leaving a miami
restaurant to the daily mail but when
kardashian used those very same images
on her instagram feed without their
permission it was available to all 67
million people who follow khloe
kardashian exposure sued kardashian for
copyright infringement in 2017 seeking
damages of more than 175 thousand
dollars for the post not that it would
have been a defense but the instagram
post didn't even credit exposure and to
add insult to injury kardashian or her
team altered the image to remove the
copyright management information the
watermark that showed exposure as the
copyright owner of the image the
copyright management information or cmi
refers to the watermark indicating where
the image has from you might have seen
things like via getty which does not
mean it was taken by a person named
viagetti it means that getty owns the
rights to that particular image now we
don't know what the final terms were in
this particular case kardashian and
exposure settled the case out of court
and kardashian deleted the post
kardashian apparently acknowledged that
she had indeed committed copyright
infringement with her instagram post she
tweeted quote yes i have to license some
of the images first a paparazzi sued me
in the past for reposting images of
myself so now it just takes me a little
longer because i have to go and license
the images so they don't get my money
bag emoji makes no sense yeah the law
doesn't make sense to chloe she after
all is not the kardashian that became a
lawyer and
in fairness other celebrities agree they
contend that they are being stalked
every day by people who want to make
money from their image and likeness and
to be fair paparazzi photogs sometimes
use special lenses to take photos of
people inside their homes famous people
like princess diana have been literally
hounded to death by overzealous
photographers but then on the other hand
there are people like lisa rina who just
says to hell with it and intentionally
and repeatedly post images that she
hasn't licensed and blatantly violating
the copyright act rina has now been sued
for over a million dollars for posting
eight photographs that she didn't
license rina said that if the
photographer had demanded a lower amount
a nominal fee she would have paid renna
and her lawyers claimed that the
copyright law was never intended to
allow photographers to profit from
images of celebrities and quote then
turn around and sue those same
celebrities for posting their own images
on social media well i hate to be that
guy but actually lisa this is exactly
what the copyright act was designed to
do the act gives creators the right to
sue anyone who infringes on their work
even if that person happens to be the
subject of the photograph but not every
celebrity has struck out making
arguments to the contrary now in 2018
gigi hadid was sued by a photographer
who took a photograph of her leaving her
apartment building hadith even struck a
pose for him the photographer worked for
the agency exclusively hadid posted the
image to her instagram without
permission or payment the agency filed
an infringement lawsuit seeking
statutory damages the law seemed to be
clear-cut in this case hadid posted an
image of herself that she didn't own
this should be a slam dunk for the
agency right well not exactly because
hadid's lawyer got the case dismissed on
a technicality the agency failed to
register the photographs before filing
the lawsuit now you don't have to file
with the copyright act to get a
copyright in something but filing your
copyright with the copyright office
gives you a bunch of benefits and the
supreme court has now ruled that actual
registration of a copyright is a
prerequisite to filing a copyright
action which resolved a long-running
split in the u.s circuit courts the new
york district court held that the
supreme court's decision foreclosed the
paparazzi agency's copyright
infringement claim against hadid however
this lawsuit turned out to be notable
for other reasons because hadid raised
some novel theories that other
celebrities are now trying to develop to
defend themselves against paparazzi
lawsuits hadid's first theory was that
she co-authored the work since she posed
and smiled under this theory she's
entitled to ownership of the image quote
because she posed for the camera and
thus contributed many of the elements
that the copyright law seeks to protect
now this is a stretch but it's not
entirely without legal basis a joint
work is a work prepared by two or more
individuals with the intention that
their separate contributions be merged
into a single work co-authors own the
works copyright jointly and equally
unless the authors make an agreement
otherwise each joint author has the
right to exercise any and all of the
exclusive rights inherent in the joint
work now the primary problem with this
argument is that for a work to be a
product of two or more creators there
must be a shared intent the photographer
certainly didn't agree with hadid that
this was a collaboration the picture was
unplanned and happened when hadid
spontaneously left the apartment but
really the whole point of paparazzi
photos is that they're taken without the
celebrity's permission and that was
argued in this particular case so it's
hard to argue the mutually exclusive
arguments that this was both unplanned
and unwanted but also it was a
collaboration where everyone intended
for their efforts to become a joint work
hadid also argued that her use of the
photographs should be considered a fair
use which we've talked a lot about on
this channel this is definitely not your
standard fair use argument and hadith
argued that when she reposted the images
she did it with a different purpose than
the agency her use was personal whereas
the agency wanted to exploit her
popularity for commercial purposes she
also argued that without her
contribution to the image it wouldn't
really exist now the court didn't
address this argument because the case
was decided on procedural grounds but
hadid sort of misses the mark when she
makes this argument the purpose of her
use really wasn't that different from
the paparazzi's use it was to exploit
her
popularity in a candid photo she wasn't
for example criticizing the composition
of the photo or using the photo for some
educational purpose this is why people
license photos that are taken by other
people she was effectively using the
photo for exactly the same reason that
paparazzi took the photo in the first
place so
well hadid made some novel arguments
they probably wouldn't hold water and
she's probably not going to change
copyright laws overnight now what about
the right of publicity some celebrities
have tried to sue paparazzi on the
theory that the photographers who profit
off of someone's images are actually
violating the celebrity's right of
publicity wide receiver odell beckham jr
sued splash news after paparazzi took
photos of an injured obj outside his
home in new jersey the photographer sold
the image to splash news and picture
agency beckham posted the image to
instagram and splash news suit him
beckham filed a counterclaim arguing
that this was an attempt to extort him
in violation of his right to publicity
after all you have a right to benefit
from your own name and likeness
otherwise everyone could simply use
photographs of you in a commercial
context so there's got to be a line
somewhere right and beckham argued in
the complaint quote splash's licensing
of photographs of an injured beckham not
only exploits beckham's image for
personal financial gain but is also
patently gruesome and while this
generally relies on state law the right
to publicity generally protects a person
from having their likeness used for
advertising or other commercial purposes
without their permission of course this
runs straight into the first amendment
because you have a right to make the
speech that you want to make and of
course in the case of odell beckham jr's
injury that's certainly a newsworthy
event which makes it receive even more
first amendment protection so generally
the right of publicity means the
photographer has the right to take
photographs of famous people and sell or
license those photographs but they can't
sell products with someone's image on
them so if you happen to get a great
photograph of odell beckham jr you could
license that photograph to a newspaper
or a magazine or sell it but you could
not however sell t-shirts or mugs
bearing the the face of odell beckham jr
only he can do that or someone that has
his permission now the obj case settled
before the court addressed his arguments
but generally they were probably going
to lose since the right of a
photographer to take the picture of a
newsworthy person is pretty well
established now if you're being hounded
by the paparazzi you'll probably need to
stay home to avoid their cameras but
luckily hellofresh today's sponsor will
deliver whether the paparazzi are there
or not and with the new year hello fresh
is a great way to eat healthily and
deliciously in fact hellofresh has a
whole variety of calorie smart carb
smart pescetarian and veggie options now
i'm a do-it-yourself person and i have
to say i was initially pretty skeptical
about hellofresh i'm a pretty good cook
so i didn't think i really needed the
help but i actually loved it even for an
experienced cook hellofresh delivers new
ingredients and recipes that i'd never
try on my own hellofresh generally keeps
everyone's favorite meals and then
rotates new ones all the time and
recently i've enjoyed crispy parmesan
chicken white cheddar wonderburgers and
pork sausage bell pepper pasta now i
don't know about you but i probably
never would have attempted those on my
own and it's not just meals hellofresh's
marketplace features a variety of
add-ons for breakfast dessert and
seasonal snacks like energy bars and
cookie dough and it saves time too i
usually increase the size of my
hellofresh serving so i can enjoy the
leftovers for lunches and of course
everything was delivered straight to my
door so i didn't have to do any shopping
the produce actually gets to you faster
than a grocery store so it arrives at
peak freshness and flavor it's also
super easy to save time hellofresh cuts
out meal planning and prep so the
recipes only take 20 to 30 minutes to
cook literally less time that it would
take to cook than it would to do the
shopping itself and it's also incredibly
sustainable since the ingredients are
pre-portioned there's less prep and less
wasted food the packaging is almost
entirely made from recyclable and
already recycled content and
hellofresh's carbon footprint is
actually 25 lower than that for meals
that are made from store-bought
groceries so if you'd like to try
hellofresh and i recommend that you at
least try it you can go to
hellofresh.com and use the code
legaleagle16
for up to 16 free meals and three
surprise gifts so again for up to 16
free meals and three surprise gifts go
to hellofresh.com and use the code
legaleagle16 or click on the link that
is below or the one that's on screen
right now and use the code legaleagle16
plus clicking on those links really
helps out this channel and while you're
at it click on this playlist over here
with my other real law reviews or i'll
see you in court